I'm intended dude [ __ ] uh-huh
yes I've been here this is where I throw
the chain and then it days they were
like glass jar container well we need
something else but I don't really know
what else did you ever know that pills
is my hair ro pizzas still weighing many
it's my chicken wings I love chicken
wings my so delicious especially spicy
one I think spicy chicken wings and beer
like a hein again that is that is life
Jen ladies and breasts that is lie
Friday
well I'm [ __ ] I don't really know our
way out of here oh no where were you
when I was looking for you well I should
dip you where is the father when you
need that [ __ ]
hey you're looking almost like the
father I'll call you Stephanie
all right but which photos files do the
ceremonial tests don't do it [ __ ] and
are you the real Stefani you shall say
what she'll say are you an akan
wonderful I love you Nicole are there
dead unique eyes okay that's cool well I
believe my work here is done nope I have
to check out this room oh that's like a
shot cut very well nice architecture
nice architecture alrighty then
hello gotta be polite can spam be angry
like pizzas all this way and all around
around around around let's pour the
actress on acid on the Tetris block
didn't [ __ ] work I guess I didn't
really think it would work and you know
here's Danny and Curtis I love you
notice this before
I mentioned it many times but I
completely lack sense of direction it's
quite quite the handicapped it's not
funny you know it's a handicap you can't
make fun of it oh man where the [ __ ] am
i all right here we are my girlfriend
actually has worse sense of direction
than me which is [ __ ] great when
we're trying to find [ __ ] okay bad luck
I disappeared it was a magic acid love
magic acid it's what I use some powdered
nope nope nope hello oh this is just bad
hello sing the graveyard song jumping to
the right ah ha ha ha ha wah wah ba-bah
ba-bah mom no probably someone else well
that's a spin eye-opening do you think
it is I think it's a penis I've never
seen anything like it I've seen that
business when I I know what penis when I
seen it yesterday afternoon one of my
good friends came in with their corpse
of a creature I'd never seen before
he claims he and his crew found it in
the mines for approximate in the past 12
hours have been examining and performing
tests this is huge discovery however I
think I should have had home free soon
virus has been adding me to spend more
time with Simon and Elizabeth and after
all I haven't been much of a father to
them lately something is weird
something odd is going on and I can't
open the corpse to the Exeter cabinets
are distinct so move slightly maybe it's
just my imagination as I don't see how
it could possibly be a lie
that's a pulse and isn't correct
responding to an external stimuli I'm
going to lock the cops up it to start
okay
Kaku when I found it in the mines it was
just laying there all right well I'll
run some tests and see if I can get any
results in the meantime you should go
back and see if you can find one alive
this could potentially be a huge
discovery
what if it elder it is a live look at
this alive ha it mom ha ha stroke that
[ __ ] look it's a surgeon simulator I'm
doing it I'm doing with that I'm doing
with that Wow
wait we'll have to continue I have to
try I know it's not gonna work
alright so we go back to the tetrax
place tetris plays
oh I'm so lucky I closed that [ __ ]
door
I'd say it's a really good custom story
man he really knows how when to scare
and when to [ __ ] oh [ __ ] there we go
hey go down the whole way to go down the
whole way go
my pulse isn't even [ __ ] working I
don't know I'm sorry about the heartbeat
not working today I don't know what the
[ __ ] is up with it
everything should be connected by the
mines I may be able to find answers down
there
I should also investigate my father safe
I think what we're going to do first is
investigate the safe or whatever the
[ __ ] because I don't know I just feel
like it yeah [ __ ] you know why what's
gonna happen it yeah okay then now we
just have to find out the riddle on the
paper or whatever I'm gonna put it up
soon I don't wanna I can't do two things
at once so bear with me for a moment so
how was your day today
very interesting okay now um where are
you all right that you are ah
that's yes four digits less than the
numbers of house in the village first
digit is 4 less that's [ __ ] weird
1 2 3 right well yes I don't know if
that one counts though
so it's either three or four [ __ ]
great we don't even know exactly what it
is next one second digit is the first
letter of my daughter's name I think it
was Margaret
oh it's Elizabeth well let's say it's
Elizabeth II a b c d 5 so 4 or 5 or 3 or
5 I'm so failing at this it's right of
my house
Wow [ __ ] wild it's gonna take me
forever all right well I should be able
to go into one of the houses now at
least so let's try this one okay that's
fantastic
lovely lovely lovely lovely lovely
lovely lovely lovely lovely lovely oh
look at that [ __ ]
well kick oh that lovely wallpaper Oh
what happened in here what a mess what a
jolly Jolly mess jolly mess Indy
well what's the [ __ ] point of this
place oh there we go one of the rods
just the 22 ROG stream that could is
Roderick dream grab a bit of a backbone
but better man F bit bill can we open
nine oh what a shame
it would seem my heartbeat sensor who
don't want to work I'm sorry about that
there's another room house [ __ ] that we
can go to and it's this one so we might
as well check it out
huh okay another house hello gentlemen
beautiful nice he had really nice hair
Alexander you can't complain but yes
Oh HS thank you pot uh-huh uh-huh what
secret lies within this storage hey rain
barrels girl I did not think that would
work
oven ah yeah blah mater yes amplitude
rod quite nice okay so we have two out
of three rods I would just guess that
the last one is in that safe or whatever
which kind of sucks well let's check in
here actually might as well today while
me and my crew were mining we stumble
across something quite remarkable it was
a corpse but I liked it I think I'd ever
seen before it looks almost demonic like
a creature from hell I wonder if I was
perhaps an discovered species living
deep underground or just in Anna Anna
Molly I can't read I'm a human source
either way I was curious and brought the
body to the morgue to be studied William
the only anatomist in the area as an old
friend of mine and was glad to help
he was astounded wasn't unlike anything
he'd seen he claimed it will take him a
few days to come up with a useful
conclusion well that's because he's sexy
you can't explain sexiness a hat I shall
wear it on my deck okay
didn't work well I don't think I can
handle this anymore we've gone too far
William we can't stop now
you're right I'm aware of the
consequences if we do my lab isn't there
another way though we've tried
everything this is the only solution
[ __ ] we are [ __ ] that's a very [ __ ]
don't do an me a very very [ __ ] you me
[ __ ] now not we're gonna [ __ ] whatever
you're crazy what happens if we enter
then from this hole or whatever was that
will that work
it's there any purpose at all for to be
here I guess we gotta check how many
indoors jaysis car
it's complicated puzzle we are I'll
punch your back I'm so happy for ya whoa
oh well one two three four
is that it hi Prez so there's four if I
understand this correct there is either
three or four
the other one is e ABCDE five three four
or five and then five three or four and
five I don't [ __ ] know
final did is amount of rooms available
in the end which was four so technically
now I can guess just guess my way on the
right of his house two barrels that's
all I can think of oh [ __ ] oh that's one
okay
you [ __ ] about got a hide secret from
it all right that means we have it and
since I don't know where the [ __ ]
sink this I thought the safe was like my
nose my nose my 9 its up
Jesus Jesus did Jesus um I thought it
was here but I can't [ __ ] open it
where do I put the dick did some kind of
mechanism [ __ ] that [ __ ]
alright after looking a lot I didn't she
I tried to cheat but I couldn't find it
but I finally noticed you can move the
bed or whatever there we are
alright this is where you enter the
[ __ ] thing at least alright let's
open yep okay so I guess we just click
these in the right order so let's see
here again let's hope I can do this if I
can do this on the first try I will eat
my own [ __ ] I mean are you nothing first
did it it's for less I think it's seven
because I don't think the in really
counts as a house so three yes okay
second digit is the first letter of my
daughter's name fine
one two three four five yeah third one
is the digits of my house was one and
the final was the rooms available in the
end which was four
what's up JD appeared strikes again wait
a break it down now come on champ his
blood is on my hands he's dead because
of me
it was necessary though I had to do it
the entire village would have been in
danger without the sacrifice the
communions purpose is to protect and I
was being able to make the difficult
decision we are here safe now because of
me I made the right choice his voice I
can't get it out of my head when I left
him there there at the table to die
it was pleading for his life begging me
to let him go back to his wife as I left
his screams occurred through the tunnels
I could hear his bones snap I didn't
know this man very well aside from
seeing and around the village that made
it easier I wonder what will happen when
someone I love gets picked from the
drawing right oh I got all the psycho
flaws I got all the psychos beat
neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh
picky those big don't figure out way to
live it up don't panic don't panic don't
fit don't panic don't panic don't panic
don't panic
don't jump-scare don't jump here don't
jump here don't jump here
oh [ __ ] how did he get out of the morgue
no bueno
it's still there it's still [ __ ]
there
there was same doctor pills prevails
once again well Lee where Lee Wei Lee
[ __ ] well quite splendid quite
splendid indeed Hybris that would mean
that would mean that we can go down the
elevator now
lovely wow what is that here Elizabeth I
want you to have this necklace ah I got
another ceremony in a few days I want
you to look nice
yeah you better Simon hello
but you can't tell them about it it's I
not yes promise okay I don't like this
what did he do to Alyssa Liu what did i
do Joanna's hello [ __ ]
well it would seem that we will have to
find out sooner or later what happened
to Lizzie Liu
okay
well here we are elevated flow flow it's
got a bit circle Trinity sounds like
three and yeah for face amplitude that's
a house [ __ ] easy
alright let's go brush in the next chef
is shown like a bird if you enjoyed this
guy come over today and I'll see you
next episode I'll bat may have you been
maybe the Nollan [ __ ] me